Move the orange dot to
9/4 on the number line.
Let's think about this
number line right here.
This is 0.
This is 3.
So this must be 1 and 2.
We need to go to 9/4.
So there's two ways
of thinking about 9/4.
One way is to try to convert
it to a mixed number.
4 goes into 9 two times.
And you'll have 1 left over.
So this you could
do as 2 and 1/4.
So you could say, this is 1, 2.
And then, we have to go 1/4
of the way between 2 and 3.
So that looks like
about 2 and 1/4.
So you could think
about it that way.
Or you could even view it
as an improper fraction.
So let's go by 1/4's.
So that's 1/4, 2/4, 3/4, 4/4,
which is a whole, 5/4, 6/4,
7/4, 8/4, which is
equal to 2 wholes.
8 divided by 4 is 2.
And then, we go from 8/4 to 9/4.
Either way, we get to that exact
same point on the number line.
Let's do a few more of these.
Move the orange dot to
11/5 on the number line.
So we can do it both ways again.
5 goes into 11 two times.
And then, you have 1 left over.
So you could call
this 2 and 1/5.
So we could go 1,
2, and then 1/5.
Or we could just
think of it in terms
of 1/5's as an
improper fraction.
1/5, 2/5, 3/5, 4/5, 5/5 is
a whole, 6/5, 7/5, 8/5, 9/5,
10/5.
10 divided by 5 is 2.
10/5 is two wholes.
10/5 and 11/5--
I'm having more fun
than I expected to
with this exercise.
Let's do one more.
Orange dot to 5/2
on the number line.
So this is 1/2.
This is 2/2, which is a whole.
This is 3/2.
This is 4/2, which
is two wholes.
This is 5/2.
Another way you could
have thought about it-- 2
goes into 5 two times
with a remainder 1.
So this is 2 and 1/2
as a mixed number--
1, 2, and 1/2 as a mixed number.